>>Reto Meier: Good morning again everyone.
My name is Reto Meier.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And I'm Ian Ni-Lewis.
>>Reto Meier: And it's time for the developers
at traveling planning and booking apps to
strike back.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: You know, every week we spend
a lot of time talking about other people's
apps, not always nicely, so today's show is
a chance for the developers of the apps we
tore apart during the app clinic-
>>Reto Meier: And put together again during
Android Design In Action, humpty dumpty style.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: to give us a piece of their
mind.
>>Reto Meier: In last week's App Clinic we
looked at these five travel planning apps.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: We learned a few things, not
the least of which is, don't trust Daniel
Pham with the sound board.
Also, five apps is too many to review.
>>Reto Meier: We also learned that people
found our featureless, black, void background
too stark reminder of their own mortality.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right, did we have that featureless
black void or are we not doing that anymore
at all?
>>Reto Meier: I think that, I don't know,
do we still have the featureless black background?
I think we're not doing that at all anymore.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Okay, yeah.
I'll take the blame on that one.
Our producers asked me to come up with something
that reflected who I was as a person and this
is what I came up with.
>>Reto Meier: In terms of apps themselves,
we came up with the following prescriptions.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: We want the apps to be consistent
with the design guide.
Don't we always want that?
>>Reto Meier: We pretty much always want that.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Indeed we do.
>>Reto Meier: In fact, that's why Roman keeps
dialing in to all of our shows, is just to
make sure that we keep pounding on that dead
horse.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Is that why?
>>Reto Meier: I'm pretty sure.
It's not for the entertainment.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: No, it's not.
>>Reto Meier: We also wanna make sure that
these apps in particular are location aware.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: We wanted them to integrate
with our digital life, you know, I use Gmail
and G Calendar for everything, other people
use, people use Facebook or different types
of things and integration with the things
that I use to organize my life is an absolute
must for travel apps.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely, and, you know, as
far as that goes, we wanna make sure that
you can plan your entire trip using the same
app.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Including all those damn guided
tours that my wife likes to go on.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Buses full of Chinese people.
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: And finally, we wanna make sure
that we can complete the entire transaction
on the device.
So we don't wanna get thrown off to a website
or a web view, if at all possible we want
that to all happen.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And I should mention, just
in case I sounded racist, my wife is Chinese
and we take the Chinese tours, that's why.
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: That makes a lot of sense.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right, exactly.
I didn't want that to sound bad.
Alright, so let's go ahead and take a look
at who we've got with us today.
We've got Goran Kukurin is it?
>>Reto Meier: I hope so.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: On the Worldscope Webcams.
Andrea Baccega of Fast Booking and Ryan Oldenberg
from Hipmunk who is joining us live in the
studio.
>>Reto Meier: Very exciting.
So he gets to see all of our disasters as
they happen in real time.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: But he does not get to appear
on the table Princess Leah style as a hologram
even though we had that totally all set up
and ready to go.
>>Reto Meier: It'll happen.
It's coming soon.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And then Reto's like "Oh,
but if we do that then I can't see my teleprompter
and how am I gonna read my awesome scripted
jokes?"
Whatever.
>>Reto Meier: Exactly.
It's just too hard.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Let's go ahead now and look
at Worldscope Webcams.
>>Reto Meier: Alright.
So, let's start off by putting up on screen
the ratings that we gave this app.
We were a little harsh, mainly because this
app didn't do a lot of the things that the
other apps did.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: We were a little unfair, actually.
>>Reto Meier: It was totally unfair.
So I'm glad that Goran is here to tell us
just how unfair we were in person.
So, hopefully we've got Goran available on
the hangout.
If we can put him on screen as well that would
be awesome.
Nice, that's kind of a funky effect with that
background.
Hey, Goran, welcome to the show.
I see you've got a partner with you as well.
If you guys want to spend a little bit of
time, just introduce yourselves, tell us who
you are and a little bit about Worldwide Webcams.
>>Goran: Okay, Hi Reto.
My partner is actually my so, one of my two
sons who both was involved in developing the
Worldscope Webcams.
My background is; I was a computer engineer
long time ago.
I started with ZX Sinclair 81.
>>Reto Meier: Nice.
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: As did I.
>>Goran: Okay, but, now for years I work professionally
work in IT and development but everything
started when I received an Android phone for
my birthday two years ago.
And with local competition, Android development
competition, and then I decided to come back
and start to learn Android.
Java and C was already known to me but Java
and [unintelligible] was something new and,
together with my team, we started looking
for idea for developing profession.
We did some research on the web on other up
source and then we decided to develop Worldscope
Webcams and in about one month of half time
working we're now straight time, Worldscope
was born.
It was version 1.0 and now, three years later,
we have almost half a million downloads and
we are looking forward to hearing feedback
from you, from Nick, from Roman and I think
the new version will come in the next weeks.
>>Reto Meier: Oh, very cool.
So you've got a new version queued up, ready
to go next week?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Excellent.
>>Goran: Next weeks.
>>Reto Meier: Next weeks.
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: That's a very important clarification.
That's really cool.
Now, I wanted to make sure that we got a chance
to bring Roman up because I know that, at
one point, Worldscope Webcams was gonna be
one of the app Android Design In Action candidates
which I think got traded out at the last minute.
So, I do hope that Roman's got some feedback
that he can share with these guys.
You're up, Roman.
>>Roman Nurik: Am I on the screen?
>>Reto Meier: You are.
>>Roman Nurik: I guess I'm on the screen.
So we actually, Nick and I provided Goran
some feedback, separately, on Google Plus.
A bunch of the feedback is really around styling,
basic visual things.
Like, one of the biggest points of ours was,
there's a case when you had the map, right,
you had the map in the background and then
images just kind of floating, I guess thumbnails
of the webcam floating over the map and it
didn't seem like there was a purpose, or it
didn't seem like there was a strong, kind
of, cue as to what was going on there so we
had made some suggestions like maybe having
a background behind those images would give
a feel of a swipeable surface where you can
go up and down, like, that's actually a list
view.
So we made a couple suggestions there, we
made a couple suggestions, like you guys said,
around, I think it was last week in the App
Clinic you mentioned like around the search
icon and things like that.
So we made a couple suggestions, in general,
around visual styling and things like that.
>>Reto Meier: Cool.
>>Roman Nurik: But one of the reasons that
we made the switch at the last minute was
that, I think it was just, you know, a little
easier for us to just think of how we can
redesign a trip advisor and Worldscope Webcams
is such a unique app that we can't just, you
know, jump in and redesign it for you, that's
part of the interesting problem of designing
such a unique app is think of a way to be
unique and present the awesome amounts of
content you have, you know, the thumbnails,
the maps and everything, in a unique way and
we didn't wanna do that for you.
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: Yeah because you didn't wanna
take away the magic, right?
Not because it was too hard work.
>>Roman Nurik: Yeah.
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Cause Roman's a hard worker.
>>Roman Nurik: Exactly.
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: You know, one thing we said,
I remember, last week about Worldwide Webcams
was is it seemed like it would work best in
conjunction with one of these other apps and
I wouldn't wanna say make it a plugin on another
app because we dinged a lot of apps for having
too many plug ins.
>>Reto Meier: Yep.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: But this is one of those times
when I really wish we had a, you know, intent
registry or something where you'd say any
travel apps that wants to use the Worldwide
Webcams functionality could fire off an intent
and get that kind of additional trip planning
feature.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely, Goran, is that something
that is already available in your app or is
this something you'd consider doing so building
an intent that a third party app developer
could use to launch your app and display webcam
for, you know, a particular location?
>>Goran: Yes, actually it is.
Worldscope webcams is reacting on geo intent
so when it receives coordinates then you will
get a list of webcams found near the specified
location.
>>Reto Meier: That's really cool.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, that is great.
Okay.
>>Reto Meier: I like that a lot.
That's exactly the way that you should be
doing things like that.
So, hopefully some of the other developers
building these travel booking apps will take
a look at that.
In fact, I think we'll ask them as they come
up.
Put them on the spot.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Indeed.
>>Reto Meier: Very nice.
So, one of the other comments that we made
that I recall was I think in terms of displaying
the content, you know, you've got this rich
visual content, it's all about the pictures
and I think one of the pieces of feedback
we had was to try and make that an even richer
experience.
So you've kind of got your full bleed images
with, you know, the descriptive text overlaying
that to make it sort of more immersive.
Is that something that you guys are considering?
Like, in terms of your overall UI, are you
pretty happy with the direction it's going?
Have you got any plans of making modifications
in that direction?
>>Goran: You have to excuse me because our
sound is not perfect so I'm not sure I understood
your question correctly but if you're talking
about your feedback from App Clinic, I totally
agree with all, all, all, everything you said.
[Laughter]
>>Goran: Especially, yeah, I mean as Nick
said before that he decided to change in the
last minute so I decided not to do some things
to be able to polish up in time.
And he already told me some of those things,
he told me one of those is really to use the
first application screen as a view pager so
you'll be able to swipe left and right but
in that case I think I will leave the map
tab completely out and put it somewhere else.
The question is, where?
[Laughter]
>>Goran: I'm not sure where but the map tab
is actually the core, core functionality when
you want to search for the webcams near a
specified point.
So, I think maybe to put a small search button
in the action bar which will then call the
map screen and then work from the screen.
>>Reto Meier: Very cool.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I think we'd encourage you
not to switch the screen immediately when
you bring up the search but once the user
is finished using the search then it's completely
appropriate to bring up that map screen.
Very cool.
>>Reto Meier: Definitely ping us when you
get another release done.
Do let us know.
We wanna make sure we go back to each of the
apps we've looked at and take a look at the
improvements and changes over time.
So, yeah, definitely looking forward to seeing
the updates when you've got them done.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Absolutely.
Thanks a lot for being with us, Goran.
>>Goran: Thanks!
>>Reto Meier: Alright.
So, let's move on before we run entirely out
of time.
I think we're up to Hipmunk, right?
So, this is the prescriptions that we had
for Hipmunk if you wanna go through those
and me and Ryan are gonna magically change
places in the background.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Absolutely.
I totally wanna go through those.
Let me find a place where I can read them.
So we felt that Hipmunk scored pretty well
on design guide consistency but where it really
shone was being location aware and integrating
with my digital life.
So, let me introduce Ryan.
He's here with us in the studio and, Ryan,
tell us a little bit about yourself and your
company.
>>Ryan: Sure, sure.
So, Hipmunk's goal is basically to try and
take travel search which is something that
everyone kind of has to do when they wanna
go on a fun trip but isn't, in and of itself,
all the exciting or enjoyable of an experience
and really kind of improve it.
And, especially, make it more mobile friendly.
It tends to be a little information overload
and, so, what we've really tried to do is
get a lot of information across in a very
visual way and the biggest thing that that's
led for us is a lot of fans of the app.
We've taken the Android design guidelines
very seriously.
We haven't done it perfectly but I think everybody's
trying to find exactly how their brand and
Android can really work together and, you
know, a little bit of harsh feedback is all
it takes to get you to really look at something
in a new way and that flexibility ends up
with a much better app.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So, I wish we could show you
the app on screen.
Today we had some issues with our MHL connector
which I'm sure many of you can sympathize
with.
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: But I've got the app in front
of me.
>>Ryan: Sure.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: and, Ryan, why don't you tell
us a little bit about, you know, what you
could change if you could.
>>Ryan: Okay, well, the first thing I definitely
agree with is that the home screen is kind
of a dashboard, kind of a list and Android's
kind of moved away from that.
The only thing that I'm afraid of if I give
this up is the, like, unavoidable knowledge
a user has the moment they launch this app
of what this app can do.
If you use a little picker on the left, which
I actually did do on tablets where this really
was very awkward, I did, unfortunately, get
a couple of emails of people asking how to
get from hotel search to flight search, which
I launched them into hotels at first.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
>>Ryan: So that's kind of made me a little
timid about it.
What approach I'm thinking of taking is instead
of kind of getting rid of a screen like this,
make it more useful of a screen.
So instead of hiding the recent searches off
in flights or off in hotels, maybe I could
put them right here in front so you could
pop right back where you were last time you
launched the app.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Absolutely.
This is really tough and I think we've, we've
had to deal with this a lot as we've switched
from the old Gingerbread design guidelines
into the Ice Cream Sandwich world is a lot
of these things are not discoverable on their
own but they become obvious over time.
You know, the same way that it used to be
that any hyperlink on a website was, you know,
underlined and in blue but it had a really
sharp "click me" attitude to it and now a
lot of times you won't even see hyperlinks
differentiated until you hover over them because
people know how they work.
So we're hoping to get to the point that people
just know how left side navigation work and
that's one of the reasons we harp on it but
you're absolutely right that adding more discoverability,
especially for new users, is a great idea.
I wanna go really quickly to Roman to see
if he's got any ideas of how you can make
things discoverable without always presenting
the user with a dashboard as soon as they
log in.
>>Ryan: Sure.
>>Roman Nurik: Yeah, so, I think the point
about, first of all just to talk a little
bit about the dashboard, I think the point
that, Ryan, you're making about having like
a more content rich dashboard, that's a good
start.
I mean, that becomes less of a dashboard and
really more of a dashboard or true dashboard.
I know that sounds weird but basically I think
that's kind of playing into what, actually
I think one of the mock ups we did for Kayak
was like, instead of having, you know, instead
of having a decision between hotels and flights,
actually show the users all this information
in one place centered around the concept of
a trip.
And that point, I mean, they don't have to
think about, you know, is there hotel functionality
search, you know, flight functionality, you
know, they just think in the concept of, "Oh,
I have a trip and here are the different things
I can do on my trip."
But to talk a little bit about the discoverability,
this is something that users of newer devices
are being trained on.
So as soon as they launch maps, as soon as
they launch Gmail, they're learning, they're
starting to understand what spinner navigation
is.
So, while there are some users that may just
not ever touch that, we're doing a better
job of training them.
So, like Ian said, it's really great, over
time this will be less and less of a problem.
But, I mean, in terms of other things, you
could have kind of a pop up, you know, kind
of blue circles indicating, "Hey, there's
more stuff here" we don't recommend generally
doing that because things like the action
bar spinner should be discoverable on their
own but if you absolutely must direct attention
to something, you could do something like
that.
And I think we mentioned this last time but
there's an open source project called Showcase
view that can kind of give you that rich,
you know, zoom in to a specific UI element.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: One thing we used to do in
video games that I think would be really difficult
to do, like would be incredibly difficult
machine learning exercise but with a video
game it was a lot easier, you could detect
when the user was frustrated and when they
couldn't figure out how to pass the level
and give them hints.
You know, I'd love it if you could say, "Oh,"
well okay, now I'm getting into clippy territory
but-
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: "Obviously you're trying to
find hotel, it's up here!"
Yeah, I like the task oriented view with the
idea that the navigation is something that
would jump you ahead or behind with the task
without having to be the only way.
>>Ryan: Yeah, to say something in less words
than the spinner, I am looking forward to
the day that that is just the way UI works
on Android.
I feel like that's a great way to do it.
Dashboards, they were kind of a solution to
a problem that's now been solved better and
we're just kind of waiting for the mainstream
to catch up a little bit.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah, I think, it's been mentioned
a couple of times already but I think the
solution which Roman's describing actually
fits in really well with one of your key points
which was the ability to plan your entire
trip so you're kind of getting away from that,
"I wanna plan a flight, I wanna book a hotel"
and you're just saying, "I wanna organize
a trip" and there's a logical work flow that
goes there.
So if you haven't done one of those elements
you're kind of prompted that, "Hey, you booked
a hotel but how you gonna get there?"
So, being able to sort of flow it that way
could be quite interesting particularly if
you can have it enter, you should have a vector
that people wanna start with.
>>Ryan: Yeah and then the sort of navigation
that doesn't feel like you go into something
and come all the way back out.
It's kind of a circle.
>>Reto Meier: Exactly.
>>Ryan: I think that could work really well.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Cool.
Now, let's talk a little bit about this.
>>Ryan: Yeah.
My favorite part of the feedback.
[Laughter]
>>Ryan: So, our location selector when you're
trying to say where you're flying from or
where you're flying to has a pretty critical
flaw in the current live version which is
that if the place you're trying to go isn't
in our auto correct library and you hit the
done button on the keyboard, it actually nukes
whatever you've typed out of existence.
[Laughter]
>>Ryan: And this is just, you know, it's a
perfect example of something I don't personally
do so I just never knew existed until I stared
it right in the face in App Clinic.
[Laughter]
>>Ryan: So that was like the best feedback
I got because I'm sure there's more than one
person out there annoyed by that.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
This is where, for those of you who can't
see the phone, this is where I type in V-E-N-I,
thinking about Venice, it gives me the choice
of either Venice, Florida or the Athens International
Airport and, yes,
>>Reto Meier: I’m gonna try to be clever,
warning.
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So it'll either give me Venice,
Florida or the Athens International Airport
and I think to myself, "Oh, neither one of
those is correct" so I hit done on the keyboard
cause I just wanna keep typing and then it
nukes what I've typed in.
>>Ryan: So this is actually an interesting
thing.
I've since fixed that.
I haven't released the update because there's
a few other things I wanna do to and I like
to be not too annoying with my updates.
But, the reason I do it is I found that when
I typed into one of these auto completes,
I would type in "San Fran" and I'd say San
Francisco and I'd be like, "Oh, actually I
didn't want that one I wanted South San Francisco"
arbitrary example, so, on the next click I
nuke whatever was in there and then what you
would type would just pop up in a little hinter.
The nice thing about that is you never have
to backspace like 30 characters you didn't
want which is kind of, extremely annoying.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
>>Ryan: The downside of that is I didn't have
the case handled for that done on the keyboard
so I was thinking you clicked on it again,
you gave it focus again by clicking on it
so whatever you typed is gone.
I've since fixed that.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: You know, I have to say I
think that you got a really good point there
but I feel like there's more to it than that
because a lot of times, cause I've seen things
that do behave the way that you're describing,
in fact, Chrome does this sometimes and it
really just kills me, I feel like I'm typing
a certain and what I really want is something
very similar to one that I've already searched
but not quite exactly the same so I want it
to auto complete and then I want to be able
to change it slightly.
>>Ryan: Chrome does that to me too.
Like, if I search two words and then I go
back and wanna search just the first, I'll
type the first and hit enter, it'll assume
I meant the whole two words and you're like,
"No!
That's not what I meant at all!"
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Exactly.
But I think we all loved your flight search
results page.
>>Ryan: That's my favorite part of the app
and I think that's pretty true for everyone.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And especially the way it
integrates with our calendar and the agony
thing, that's awesome.
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Although, I think I mentioned
I really wanted more to it.
>>Ryan: Yeah.
So the balance we're trying to strike there
is, the best mobile apps tend to do like a
core set of things and it's easy to like,
keep adding features as you finished some
and you kind of have the dev time, or something
like that and, like, frequent flyer miles,
you know, selecting preferred airlines and
all that stuff could be really cool to tuck
in there somewhere but I don't know if I'm
entirely convinced that just keeping it very
simple is the worst idea.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I think you're absolutely
right but I would counter with, sort of, what's
worked for us at Google which is you wanna
keep the interface very, very simple.
I don't want anything to change in what I
just did but I wanna have that magical feeling
of realizing, "Oh, hey, the results you gave
me fit my life perfectly because I don't just
have a calendar.
I also tend to fly this airline or I want
a window seat or I've got this many frequent
flyer miles."
>>Ryan: You make a good point.
The distinction between UI, like screen space
being taken up by something, an actual functionality,
it is actually not unreasonable to think we
could add that in, sort of, a setting screen
where you don't even have to know it exists,
it doesn't clutter anything to do with what's
already been done but you can get the benefit
of it if you want it.
That's pretty reasonable.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Absolutely.
There are a few things, you know, for instance,
the agony of a particular flight goes down
if this long layover happens to be in a place
with a really good frequent flyer club, for
instance.
>>Ryan: Yeah, definitely.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: But what are the color codings
mean?
>>Ryan: So, colors are specifically chosen
to be, like you guys hit on it when you were
talking in the App Clinic, it's to do with
airlines.
So, Delta's blue, United, or Delta's orange,
United is blue and NA is like a light green.
We tried to do it as true to the colors they
picked for their brand as possible.
In truth, we could have done arbitrary colors
but since it was already gonna be kind of
a rainbow we tried to give as much meaning
to it as possible.
For most people who don't really care about
the names of the airline or the color of the
airline it's just nicer looking than a whole
bunch of the same color.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: That's a really good point.
I would love to see a feature where they're
separated by alliance because there's only
like four alliances that make any difference
at all.
>>Ryan: Yeah, well that's the, the biggest
thing is often people think that they want
a preferred airline but really they want a
preferred alliance.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Absolutely.
>>Ryan: So, stuff like that can really make
a difference.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, I can see how you could
really change things around.
Well, I think we're almost out of time but
let's just really quick talk about the hotel
search which we thought was very similar in
a lot of ways to flight search.
It felt like some things were missing, like
there weren't as many, I don't think you have
the previous searches listed.
>>Ryan: Yes.
So I do have them in the background but the
big design goal when they originally designed
hotels or what I call intels which is our
hotel search product, which is that you were
always looking at the map, you never lost
this anchor, which you guys even picked up
on in the App Clinic cause you couldn't really
get away from the map until you picked a hotel.
The downside of that is there's not really
room to put a big list that needs a bunch
of screen space.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Of course.
>>Ryan: So, really it was just one of those
things we just kind of had to give up and
what I like about potentially bringing a combined
list of recent searches to the dashboard is
suddenly you haven't given up that recent
search list and I think that can make up for
it.
In general, flights is, flights and hotels
were both designed in two different eras so
flights was originally designed back when
Gingerbread was the king and ICS didn't even
exist and Honey Comb was just on tablets,
which I think it's always just on tablets,
but just on early tablets.
Then I did hotels before I had an ICS phone,
though I think it had been announced, so the
flavor of the time is like very visible in
the design.
Flights I've done a lot of work to bring up
to ICS, I'm moving over to doing that on hotels
but that's why while there's an action bar
it's kind of not quite right and why there's
two floating buttons on the bottom left as
opposed to a vertical action bar.
At the time these things just didn't quite
exist for me and so, you know, just the flavor
of the time.
But I look forward to fixing it.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Awesome.
Well, I think that given what you've told
us about when it was designed I think you've
done a fantastic job.
I really appreciate you coming in, thanks
a lot.
>>Ryan: No, definitely.
It's been great.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Why don't we bring Reto back
up here and let's talk about our very last
app which I think is KAYAK.
>>Reto Meier: Well, actually, we kept them
in the same order as last time so just in
case,
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: We're mentioning KAYAK.
>>Reto Meier: Exactly.
Just in the off chance that one of the KAYAK
folks stopped in while we were on air and
they haven't as far as I know.
So we're gonna skip past KAYAK and, instead,
I think we're gonna look at FastBooking which
we have Andrea Baccega available on the hangout
on air for us.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Alright.
Andrea.
>>Andrea: Hey, how are you?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Very good.
How are you?
>>Reto Meier: Very good.
Thank you for joining us.
What time is it in, I'm gonna go ahead and
presume you’re in Italy at the moment?
>>Andrea: Yes, I am in Italy.
[Laughter]
>>Andrea: It's 10 after 9 right now.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: That's not so bad.
>>Reto Meier: That's a reasonable, that's
a reasonable time.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So where are you located,
Andrea?
>>Andrea: Sorry?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Where are you located?
What city?
>>Andrea: I am in Jesolo which is a city near
Venice.
It's about 30 kilometers from Venice.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Oh, quite close then.
>>Reto Meier: Nice.
So, yeah, so you developed FastBooking and,
in fact, we looked at your app because you
pinged me and said, "Please, take a look at
FastBooking" so we did and I think we gave
quite a bit of feedback.
I think some of it was a little critical so
I really wanna give you the chance to tell
us a little bit about the concept behind the
app, how happy are you with where it's at
now and, sort of, what are your plans for
how you may want to improve it in the future?
>>Andrea: Yeah, we decided to have a new version
of FastBooking application because we already
had the ones before but it was designed a
couple of years back so the design was, well,
it was okay at that time but now was outdated
so we decided to have a new revamped design
that was right.
So we did a new version of the application.
We decided to have a flat design with flat
buttons.
We decided to have the same color palette
that we have on the FastBooking.com website
so, actually, the color scheme can change
because we have same colors on the website
so we decided to have the color identity on
both products.
>>Reto Meier: That makes a lot of sense.
Particularly for an app like this there's
a reasonable chance that you're gonna have
people migrating from the web to the phone
and vice versa so having that consistent branding,
I think, makes a lot of sense.
>>Andrea: Yeah, so, we decided to have with
this application the new version and we, as
I already said, we redesigned it from scratch.
The basic features of the application is that
you can actually find hotels based on the
check in date, the number of heads, the number
of nights and you can search for the city
and then you can go forward and you can see
the reviews and the photo galleries for the
pictures of the rooms and etcetera.
>>Reto Meier: That's right.
That was the thing which we highlighted as
one of the real features of the app, I think,
was the gallery with the rich photos.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: That's really useful, yeah.
>>Reto Meier: It looks really, really nice.
>>Andrea: Yeah.
So, and then you have, obviously, the ability
to book the hotel and actually also have the
ability to bookmark one so if you decide to
bookmark it and review it later with your
girlfriend to see if she wants to go there
and you can book it afterwards if you want.
So it's actually only for hotels application.
You, it's not like Hipmunk that does almost
everything in your trip.
>>Reto Meier: Well, they're just showing off.
>>Andrea: Well it's the-
[Laughter]
>>Andrea: and that's it, I mean, we have a
number of things and I think it's interesting
for developers.
For example, we have on the booking form,
which is the booking page where you enter
your personal data like first name, credit
card and the address, etcetera, in order to
validate the booking process.
You have a validation procedure that helps
the user understand where they failed to enter
their data.
For example, if they enter a number in first
name we're not saying you did it wrong we
are going to say, "Enter the first name" or
edit text where you made a mistake.
You did it wrong because there are numbers
in there that should be only alphabetical
characters and this is a nice thing that we
didn't see in other application.
But this is one of the most particular thing
that we created and we use a lot of catches
in order to cache the thing that we download,
for example, the images that you get on the
list are downloaded only once.
So if you search menus for today and you go
tomorrow and you reopen application tomorrow,
you are going to have the cached content instead
of reloading everything.
We are going to cache the offers, the rooms,
everything, almost everything because we want
you to have the application to move fast.
>>Reto Meier: Cool.
Yeah, I think that's a really key thing, particularly
on mobile which I think people who are used
to developing on the web especially, don't
necessarily take as much advantage of because
to them it's like, well, internet connections
will always be faster, the whole things not
gonna work if you're not online so there's
not really the same opportunity.
But, for mobile, doing that caching is vital,
you know, it's gonna cut down on your mobile
traffic, it's gonna make the whole app just
feel faster and more responsive so I think
it's a really important step.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Absolutely.
>>Reto Meier: And I love data validation that
tells you what you're doing wrong so thank
you for that.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Oh yeah.
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: I mean, there's nothing more
frustrating than hitting submit and you just
get like, usually it's an alarm at the top
of the page which you won't scroll to, it's
just nothing happens except some of the data
gets erased and if you scroll back up to the
top it goes, "Yeah, you didn't fill in something
right."
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Although I've gotta say it
seems like your discriminating against people
whose first name do contain numbers.
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: Well, I think when you do change
your name so that the "I"is replaced with
a "1" you're kind of asking for trouble.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, but I am actually a
little sensitive to this because when I got
married my wife and I decided to hyphenate
our last name and a lot of-
>>Reto Meier: Oh they don't let you hyphenate.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: websites don't take the hyphen.
>>Reto Meier: That's kind of harsh.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: It's a little odd isn't it?
>>Reto Meier: Are you sure?
Maybe it's-
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: There are quite a few hyphenated
last names.
>>Reto Meier: Maybe it's just like generally
a keyboard only has like the minus sign which
isn't like an EN dash.
So, maybe that's the problem.
You need to get a real dash.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: It's not a EN dash, it's an
N dash.
>>Reto Meier: Well that's what, either way,
either way.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Okay.
>>Reto Meier: It's still a minus which isn't
the same as either, so.
Try that next time.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I have to assume, though,
that if I did that it would always print out
as like backslash something.
>>Reto Meier: Or like a, it could be a square.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Like the Microsoft quotes
that you see everywhere.
>>Reto Meier: Oh, yeah, my favorite is on
word when it loses images it just has a big
square with a red "X" through the middle.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, that's rough.
Anyway, something to think about.
Yeah, we love the, we love the validation
that's a little bit more lightweight and user
responsive, we love the caching, we just have
a few more seconds left to go, Andrea, but
can you give us any ideas about what's coming
in your next release?
>>Andrea: Well, in the next release we are
going to fix any minor bugs that we have,
we are going to have a better Google integration
so we are going to check out the ecommerce,
so we are going to know each transaction and
how much and where each transaction comes
from.
>>Reto Meier: Nice.
>>Andrea: We are going to have a contact picker
so that the user will be able to fill the
booking information so first name, last name,
the one that we talked about before, picking
from their contact list.
>>Reto Meier: Oh, that's good.
>>Andrea: So if you have your own contact
with the address etcetera you can just pick
your content and everything is already filled
for you.
>>Reto Meier: That's great.
Anything that requires less input.
>>Andrea: We are going to have multiple offers
which aren't currently available because you
only are, in the lite version you currently
are able only to book the best offers, the
best offer, only the best offer and now you
can choose between the multiple offers.
For example, if you want to choose [unintelligible]
version, I guess, to the best one, you can
just pay more and you can do it.
[Laughter]
>>Andrea: So that's the stuff that is going
on in the next release.
>>Reto Meier: Very cool.
And I have one more suggestion which I'd really
like to see you guys do because I'd like to
see what kind of results you get.
So, I think, from memory, yours was one of
the, one of if not the only app which didn't
have a feature graphic for it.
So when we put up the big screen of all of
the apps we were looking at, you know, we
didn't get to do anything but have an icon
for you guys.
So we saw a study on the web that showed that
one of the apps which was being featured found
that their traffic doubled when they had a
feature graphic.
Now,
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: It wasn't just having one
it was also having a really good one.
>>Reto Meier: A really good one, that's right,
that's right.
It has to have one to be featured to begin
with.
So they went from kind of a "eh" graphic to
a really nice one and doubled their install
rate.
I'd be really interested to see if you guys
did something like that, create a feature
graphic, try and make it as compelling and
interesting as possible and see if that has
any impact on your downloads.
I rather suspect that it will but it would
be great to find out from you guys whether
or not my supposition is correct.
>>Andrea: Well, we'll definitely do it.
We will let you know.
>>Reto Meier: Cool.
I look forward to it.
Alright, thank you very much for joining us
Andrea.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Keep in touch.
>>Andrea: Thank you.
>>Reto Meier: Okay, so, I don't the TripAdvisor
guys have stopped by so we've got their scores
up on the screen, give them a couple seconds.
Nope.
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: So that, I think, puts us out
of time for today.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Very much so, yes.
>>Reto Meier: So let's have a look.
Let's give a bit of a shout out to stuff that
we've got coming up.
So, next week's App Clinic we're looking at
video players.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Something near and dear to
my heart.
>>Reto Meier: Indeed.
So the four apps that we're looking at are,
in fact, going to be NX Player, Dice Player,
Netflix and CDX Player and three of these
apps have something in common.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Indeed.
They do not have a feature graphic.
>>Reto Meier: So we're really hoping that
if the developers of these apps happen to
be watching or happen to catch this on YouTube,
that they go ahead and create feature graphics
sometime between now and tomorrow afternoon.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Indeed.
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Or we'll create them for them.
>>Reto Meier: Excellent.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: How about that?
>>Reto Meier: Fan drawn feature graphics.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
>>Reto Meier: Should be fun.
So this is gonna be tomorrow at a brand new
regular time of 10:30 AM Pacific Time.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yes, although I did want to
talk to you about that because I'm usually
hungover then so we might wanna change.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah, we'll have a look at it.
In fact, you guys can let us know if, we used
to do this at like 1:00 in the afternoon which
was, on a Friday afternoon, late enough to
not be suffering from a hangover, early enough
to start working on the next one.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
>>Reto Meier: So it kind of had its advantages.
10:30 works a little better for our European
people who don't have to stay up late on a
Friday night at home just to join us in a
hangout.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Indeed.
>>Reto Meier: But this is tomorrow so please
do tune in and hopefully we'll get some of
these developers back next week for Developers
Strike Back as well.
So that's all for us.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Absolutely.
>>Reto Meier: Thank you for watching and thank
you very much to all of our developers who
came in, both in the studio and via hangout
to talk a little bit about their apps.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Take care.
>>Reto Meier: And see you next week!